[Music]
hey guys what's going on this is my
basement this is my friend Joe hello
he's an excellent writer and spider-man
expert and today we're going to be
playing a lot of spider-man games I
thought it'd be fun to do a new segment
where before a big movie comes out we
try to get our hands on as many games of
that franchise as possible whether it's
new or old we try to get the actual
physical media in our hands to play the
game and see if we can even get remotely
far because some of these I've played in
some of these I haven't we pulled our
collections between the two of us at
which games we had I did something like
this in the past when my friend Matt and
I reviewed jaws movies leading up to the
shallows we played Jaws video games I
did something like this with my wife
before we played Superman 64 and I don't
know I want to do more game content a
lot of people request more game content
I'd like to do that for you guys
a buddy of mine mr. Sunday movies does a
segment called the caravan of garbage
where before a big movie comes out he
will review or talk about something
whether it's a game or something related
to said movie and we had a little
discussion on Twitter to make sure we
weren't stepping on each other's toes
he's a really cool guy all - link for
his channel in the description below
definitely subscribe to his channel and
check out his stuff without further ado
are you ready to play spider-man aren't
you ready I'm very ready I don't think
we can beat all of these I mean we have
lives that's true we really don't so
maybe if we can maybe we can get a lot
of farther than we expect let's get
going with the very first one
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening New York my name is of no
importance
I am merely a concern for the Sigma
citizen who has learned of something
masters the renegade done is spider-man
is seeking revenge upon you
here's hidden the bomb which will
explode in executive fuck you kingpin oh
my god it may please postulate is that
am a or am i protecting at may you can't
even punch her what I think that's a cop
I think I think I just murdered a
policeman what and they got away because
this is actually kind of fun
oh my god people are coming out on
windows to kill spider-man can't looks
like surgeon
get out of here users they're all the
same people
yes I like how he like he kind of flips
down the window watch oh hell that's
actually kind of cool
he can't always stick to the window hmm
that's a Riddler or Robin Hood no don't
tell me I gotta kill a German Shepherd
I'm sure you get escaped before you I
want to come come on there you go a
bitch is that ref yep the rats hurt you
to stay where rats anyway okay I think
I've I think I've figured things out
here there we go
eat my webs bitch what I think I went
him I went him to continue oh no now I
have to learn their controls
all you just to continue you just beat
up a cop I guess this game was ahead of
its time septa yeah see I was laughing
when you were doing this before now I'm
seeing Mike slightly more complicated
than you might expect per punch kick
jump web ok catalyst
no yes can't wave him the evil into that
like every like yeah right right that
German Shepherds ready to kill you oh
he's control sock hey he's treating me
back okay there we go I like how all you
have to do is duck and he can't get you
where'd he go
I don't see if anymore basically you can
win up you can beat the entire game in
one sitting if you just crouch the whole
time
and that's exactly what I'm gonna do
yeah who needs work but I just suck
those goons in green pants and brown
jacket are going to kill you man no
they're all the same yeah did you what
that how is that that was awesome
oh you broke your jaw and I think it was
just like frenetic speed it let you get
too hippy do I get to kill a cop yeah
boom fuck you police officer
[Applause]
[Music]
there's no way to sit you have a certain
amount of luck you have a certain my
lives you have to get through the entire
game with you do not get extra lives
that's a jump on a job and you have to
beat as every character of the x-men and
spider-man if you die before the end
that's it and you just restart yep oh
there's like a pal no it's 1000 it
pissed me off so it's like I only got
through I think three people I can't
even read it away no it's so pixelated I
love me some retro games but I cannot
read that okay let's try to read I know
that truck arcade I have to go after
them the lives of the x-men depend on me
get ready spider-man okay what the hell
do I do
oh fuck now if I recall with this one
you have to hit each one of those as
they're blinking you can't get and you
can't pick them up though until there's
like each you have to get them in a
certain order
oh are they like a checkpoint yes there
hmm for his level for this one you have
to go in strict order I think this one's
outside done okay so I got to go out
back out there yeah it's been a while
hey how do you cook I think you jump on
that window now I'm trying to figure out
how to spin a web up like I was just
doing it there we go that's good old
Sega Genesis control oh god there's a
flying drone and the drone from the year
2016 apparently I can't you shooting
golf balls at you there we go
wow he's a strong one ha take that all
right here we go
yeah you know I'm afraid to jump huh
yeah yeah
ah I don't care about the blinky things
I don't care well you have to get him to
go to the next level done 40 what yeah I
know you have to what is this Tetris yes
we did I don't know I don't care help
this run is straight up Tom Cruise ha ha
Tom Cruise spider-man so I got to go all
the way back and find the little blinky
blue dots yes that's that's what I want
a spider-man game I don't want to swing
around town I want to collect blinky
lights yes sure
1993 spider-man creators how dare you so
I got to go all the way back up there ok
so basically this is not actually a
spider-man game it's collect the blue
well mainly for this one I do remember
that it's only really both thank God
Oh so we would just follow spider-sense
ah we have the privilege of creating a
spider-man game for the masses we will
make him go through tunnels and collect
blue light all right
hey that's the last one you know this
reminds me of why the Rings in Superman
64 I get to be a superhero let's just
run around and collect rings and what
and you get run as Tom Cruise as time
for this alright alright well done buddy
whoa it's like back in 1993 the
developers were like ok we need to have
Wolverine in this game and we need to
have kids play it so what can Wolverine
constantly killed and we won't have any
angry letters from parents Wow Turkish
people almost dead oh no oh did he just
get sliced up by by the Indiana Jones in
manual pass Travie was going to say
[Applause]
you
okay this already looks awesome okay
whoa okay
I feel like I've I feel like we've
traveled into their future here we go
come here guys come here every one of
these games has like twins and triplets
and quadruplets oh there's another one
there's like I still got a scanner bro
like right there who's attacking spider
ping is he wearing a Captain America
shirt who is he fighting right now the
common citizens are approaching him Hey
hi my bed
can we have a lotta grass no safer here
no you want to say hi to me because I'm
saving your neighborhood well no point
you and so it is coming here that's it
now I get to go over here put some more
it looks sort of like a gambit combined
with Doc ah ah and then there's like a
skater bro like just in the middle of it
all Oh life look at this shit look at
that shinning like a shimmying look for
sex yeah hmm oh I like how they gather
the villains have names
Oh Alex George oh sweet off breads Jeon
Wonju often Alex any brand of I Brett by
Lynn kids Alamo
ha ha ha ha ha Mike when Alamo remember
the Alamo not anymore
Oh oh my god this games incredible
oldham t put your hair the whole game is
amazing are you fight don't you look it
looks like you're beating up like yeah
like female softball players
[Applause]
welcome true believers and newcomers
alike
mitem and co-creator stanley here once
again we find our hero Peter Parker
better known around the world is the
amazing spider-man in an equal I
genuinely so happy that Stanley has been
able to like see Oh humungous like his
universe and the character the
characters he worked on have become it's
so great from blocky polygons to I bet
the movie when will they bug black cat
movie for real
what are you soon sorry even even
they're like look at that from that
angle
oh yeah spiders like move shit let me
look a little closer
alright where's wig no what do I do
here we go boom oh all right you big fat
buffoon down well good old older games
way of people dying to just disappear
the nothing there's probably some key
some poor kid who kills like you're not
disappearing
why are you doing being this isn't what
spider-man hold up I'm you have just
committed murder minor man said it would
be okay
goddamn it said I could punch someone up
a building it's nothing what happened oh
I like how this actually just you can
crawl on walls without having to hold a
button
no thank goodness pick up the chair oh
the chair yeah WWE is s chair okay now
we're all worse what happened I don't
know the camera won't show me
I'm coming at you beat up those polygon
old structures I make them vanish into
thin air just like in real life yes
that's how murder works in the actual
world and it doesn't you can kill as
many people as you want because they all
simply vaporize okay I was you had me
worried there for a second
spider-man the game run around a
business building well I just I'm so
excited to play spider-man ah another
office building just like dad
yes mommy I get to be like dad and work
in an office except some spider-man
[Applause]
that's a bad day for spider-man like
Sandman venom doc doc ock and Goblin all
in one place
and the new Goblin okay so this is this
end like the movie chronology ah sure
looks like my guess this isn't where no
one dies is this cannon I I'm very
interested suddenly in this I'm very
confused
whoa well that's fucking cool why is
that not a place every single spider-man
game hey Fred leave a Smackdown on that
guy do it again
all right very come here you some of it
oh wow
oh that is satisfying hi chef
[Laughter]
some good shit I like how destroying the
men gives you a nice bridge all
construction work is done by killing
people and then you create it that's how
you build bridges
well I murder oh oh you can able own up
right there surprisingly satisfying ah
just want to get everyone it's
surprising room very very cathartic just
every single project come here bro oh
wow he's right in the lobby at least
you're not fighting a softball playing
women anymore we just wanted to play a
[Applause]
new game style closing the wire yeah I
think Maguire does the voice for
spider-man 1 2 & 3 all the game I think
it is the voice force you have another
reason why I enjoy his portrayal so much
he actually voiced the games I love what
actors do that when they were like yeah
I'll voice the character in the game I
think Christian Bale even voiced Batman
in the Batman Begins games very good for
games even ps2 I'll check those out
that was the coolest fucking thing I've
ever seen
oh ho this is supposed to be discussed
territory oh yeah I instantly remember
everything
hell yeah look at shit I remember being
so excited about this it's the fact that
you could like swing around in the city
now what they really improved upon which
will play soon the second one with
swinging like in this first one you
could swing indefinitely look there are
no buildings around it like what the
hell is he swinging on who knows put the
flower dad I got the clouds and the
second one you actually have to swing
like there have to be the logic
everybody yeah I did like that little
symbol you look cool they actually did a
pretty good job with this game I mean
just look at that also do you really
want to be thinking about logistics what
your websley not to know not in the game
but I'm like really like in that new III
spider-man the new spider-man game they
were showing high-energy fight and I am
excited
[Music]
you are swinging from the Sun happily
it's a wiffle okay don't die catch Uncle
Ben's killer I can't see a thing
if I found him I wouldn't know what do
you do well if only I could see Uncle
Ben's killer
there we go or something you see those
heavily shadowed areas oh I see them
Bruton Campbell oh my gosh isn't that
great they got Bruce Campbell do the
voice for like the hint and that's
obviously better than black hat hell
yeah that's better
[Applause]
the animation for swinging to is great
like you could you could kind of like
jump off of a wall and then go through
like a like the corridor building plexus
it's the best man Spidey 2 is great like
this was easily I remember playing this
like okay this is a good movie based
game you know because you know like most
movie based games are fucking terrible
but it wasn't legitimate Lee Goodwin I
could honestly just play this game and
just swing for hours that's how much fun
is famous oh my god oh that is
satisfying look at look at boom
goodbye robbers one more somewhere oh
yeah mmm look at you just keep doing
even though they're out there already
knocked out cold you can keep being shit
haha hahaha oh okay let us ride this car
for a while basically this game was one
of the first Spidey games that was kind
of open world you could go around New
York and just save random citizens you
basically do are and you can jump off
the end of the rope a day wow you got to
Jesus we used to find yeah ha ha ha
spider-man 2 Messiah good Oh
oh okay you see ours ringing hilarious
[Laughter]
okay
this is our drug spider Megan all right
I'm ready are you ready it's got a
button master Joe you know dad I don't
know why you're doing or just oh I'm
going to be a history somehow but you
are certainly using a lot of webbing I
[Applause]
remember this game being just about as
disappointing as the movie because like
spider-man 2 the movie and the game were
so great and it's like for some reason
when it came around to this third one
everyone involved just like yeah we're
done
whatever the good rod let's just make
some money yep I still sometimes will
think about like what they could have
done with spider-man 4 and I get like oh
my god and I could net it out of it so
cool John Malkovich yeah I think they
were thinking about Malkovich for
vulture yeah yeah and Hathaway is black
cat which is so that Catwoman so she
can't complain too much Keaton is good
as voltar I'm very happy with this
portrayal it's just that there are days
where I think man would have been great
if you could ever deemed himself and
then one more spider-man liner yeah so
the camera in this game is atrocious I
am John Calley running into the fire
over again I suck yeah I rescued
civilian
don't worry about what the hell is your
husband you're Dennis spider-man thank
you for much
I hate these X's over them it just looks
like I'm fighting an X we can write up
to your oh it's very distracting that
poster image is one of my favorite
Spidey posters that is really good it
was so great I wish that the movie was
as good as that yeah
[Applause]
yeah amazing spider-man 2 the game has
probably my favorite web slinging of any
spider-man game I mean Spidey 2 for
GameCube and ps2 and everything that
really kind of introduced you so like
how great it could feel when you spend
webs but this game I think perfected it
plus the graphics are just the best
obviously but this I actually think it's
a fairly underrated spider-man game I
obviously like it a lot more than the
film I don't even own the film
I'm sorry own the game did you ever play
that spider-man cartoon maker game on PC
you know you could create your own
spider-man comic it was like a you could
make your own motion spider-man comic it
was like on Windows 95 or something
great ooh oh look at it it's like bitch
that's fun man awesome thanks a lot for
joining us back spider-man has a long
history of beating up faceless shoes and
women for no reason to like they're just
they could be asking for an autograph
they could just be saying hi nope I'm
John you're going down guys thank you
very much for watching look forward to
spider-man homecoming it's definitely
worth checking out in the future I'd
like to do more things like this I think
my friend Matt and I are going to try to
play a Planet of the Apes game before
war for the Planet of the Apes because
we looked at Planet of the Apes games
there's like one it's like one Planet of
the Apes game and of course it's from
Tim Burton's remake from like 2001 yeah
so if you can't play as Mark Wahlberg
I'm going to be disappointed you could
argue that you play Donkey Kong for that
that's true that's true we play Donkey
Kong games okay guys thank you so much
as always for watching I look forward to
doing more fun stuff like this you guys
are the best as always if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]